there's one chart that I consider the
chart of the year it shows Fiat
currencies with the US dollar continuing
to strengthen while every other fiat
currency in the world continues to
weaken this is the dollar milkshake
Theory playing out in real time as we
look at this chart we can see that the
US dollar is the choice currency in the
flight to safety investors around the
world they're scared there's uncertainty
and there's chaos in the market they
want US dollars in order to protect
themselves as we've seen Bitcoin has
drawn down 70 since November but in
recent weeks Bitcoin and the US dollar
hold strong while every other currency
is completely collapsing but
understanding where we've been is only
part of the story we also need to
understand where we are going as will
Clemente pointed out Q4 historically has
been the best quarter for Bitcoin
performance it averages over a hundred
percent return through bitcoin's life
cycle on top of that October and
November are the two top months for
bitcoin's performance they have gone up
28 and 54 percent respect actively does
seasonality matter we're about to find
out continue to pay attention not only
where we've been looking at the chart of
the year and understanding that the
dollar is reigning Supreme and bitcoin's
holding in there much much stronger than
many other currencies but also where
we're going in Q4 having that great
seasonality over the years the past May
repeat or it may not but you got to pay
attention to understand what happens
next these updates are brought to you by
FTX if you want to go ahead and buy
Bitcoin and use super cheap fees you can
go in the description and click on the
link there and you can use FTX which is
85 cheaper than some of their
competitors FTX continues to innovate in
financial markets I think you'll enjoy
using that product